i don't know if you're talking about
like was justice league two gonna happen
it's just a sleep three gonna happen
should we restore the snider verse and i
don't think everyone knows where we
already stand on that point
people are putting out their ending
explains and spoiler review videos and
i'm sure there's some people who are
like why the hell are you talking about
this greg
but i i i do got to say like it's
it's really this story for some reason
have any of the stories come out this
week in particular
green lantern was supposed to be in the
original ending a whole bunch of jazz
it's this one that is my favorite
happy zack snyder's justice league day
people whoever is lucky enough to access
it or whoever
has been able to see it i hope you did
we love it by the way the full length
watch along where you sync up watch
along with us that'll be available
on our patreon tonight or tomorrow
uh we just gotta work on uh assembling
it the reaction highlights for
it will be up i don't know hopefully in
a week or two it's gonna be a long edit
that's for sure but uh watch along we'll
be at our patreon
and also we'll be doing a spoiler talk
for it probably a live stream uh this
coming saturday to give people time to
watch it and get as many people on that
stream as possible so we can be
overwhelmed and get anxiety during it
answer all your questions about the cut
so would today
you know i felt like i wanted to talk
about something snyder cut related i
came across this story
that just broke my heart uh
and it touched my heart it's beautiful
broke my heart and and and like that
sad side but then in the like oh my god
that is so
touching to me this is so by it yeah i'm
very much moved by it so this is gonna
be some slight spoilers here
uh for the movie like i don't think
they're big spoilers in terms of plot
however if you haven't
seen the movie or if you don't you don't
care you can say but
if you haven't seen the movie i think
it's better for this to be experienced
so while it's not like
a big plot point that is that that is uh
you know like significant like oh my god
i still think it works better if you've
like just don't see the scene coming you
know so basically this actress named c
amanda mod chinese chinese-american
actor who lives in london
and um man boys this one really does get
to me
so she put out this tweet
yesterday saying snyder cut i was cut
from the whedon version
can someone please let me know if i'm in
this version trying to figure out how to
view it but please let me know if i made
this cut on the single mom waitress in
cyborg's backstory now
i put out this uh twitter this tweet i
don't know why i was like so [ __ ]
emotional over this [ __ ]
so i put out there i put out this tweet
uh where like a couple days ago
basically about like there's a cyborg
scene
it got us both really emotional and i
was pretty angry that it was cut
and it's actually like involving his
whole backstory and
plus her specific scene
[Laughter]
i really identify sympathize with that
damn [ __ ] talk about the the heart
that's that's heartbreaking how
dare they cut those scenes out of the
movie
like damn that actually
angered me that those were not in the
utter cut
man that was talk about doing a
disservice to a character oh
boy i know the reaction's not available
right now but i'll just tell you what
the scene is
cyborg he basically starts to really
learn
and embrace his powers more and within
there he basically sees this whole
woman's life story
through likes all levels of hidden
security cameras all over the world and
watching her struggle
as a single mom and then at the end
of that scene just replaying it in my
head it just gets me and then
uh at the eight and then when he follows
her to the atm
where she and and then he like loads her
account with just so much freaking money
he
likes so much goddamn money and then
she's just so happy
and it's like it's such a heroic robin
hood beautiful moment
and i'm like damn she didn't get to see
that [ __ ] and that's
that was one of my favorite scenes in
that whole four-hour movie
it it is one of my favorite scenes and
uh
it it like it just breaks my heart like
that scene breaks my heart and then to
know like oh man
she didn't get to experience that and
then just to see like
it's got like 890 retweets um a [ __ ] ton
of comments and just like
so many people just came in to just be
like hey you're awesome you're the best
you're one of the best parts of this
movie and like she's this asian american
actress and i don't know especially with
like
the way the scene is my parents were
never divorced but my mom was the
breadwinner in the family she was
often like the only one working and
she's asian so
there's something about that that i
really felt connected to
especially with like struggling with
money growing up and then to see her
like follow-up tweet
where she said nothing like this has
ever happened to me before thank you
everyone for all the kind words and
support thank you to everyone that made
the snyder cut
possible and i'm like see this is why
this this like
i don't know if you're talking about
like was justice league two gonna happen
it's just a sleek three gonna happen
should we restore the snyder verse and i
don't think everyone knows where we
already stand on that point
people are putting out their ending
explains and spoiler review videos and
i'm sure there's some people who are
like
why the hell are you talking about this
greg but i i do got to say like
it's it's really this story for some
reason have any of the stories to come
out this week in particular
green lantern was supposed to be in the
original ending a whole bunch of jazz
it's this one that is my favorite so far
absolutely because this
represents the best of what you know
this whole
fan interaction with the big machine can
offer you is like really people can be
vindicated and see their work done
justice too you know not to pull a pun
there but yeah i mean you know between
the charity work that this movie has
helped drum up the awareness for
suicide prevention and whatnot and then
things like this that are so personal
for someone to be validated this way and
to be
embraced by a ton of strangers you know
and to i bet to be given all that
news in such a deluge has to be one of
the most unique moments in anyone's life
and so yeah
it's interesting to see i mean not you
know to say that this
woman's life is exactly like the
character she played in the movie or
anything but yeah i mean that is one of
the things that
really shows why that cut stands above
the other one it's a moment they didn't
have to put in at all i feel like
other movies did obviously wouldn't have
cared to include and yeah it's things
like that that exemplify i think the
best
all around of what this experience has
offered us you know with like cyborg's
backstory in that
scene too it just it's such a power like
a big part of what upset me about
all this being cut out especially with
cyborg's backstory is but cyborg
he's got such a tragic turn of events
from going from victor stone into cyborg
and he just kind of hates himself and is
ashamed and it's
this moment here where he starts to
realize the good he can actually do
and like the possibilities she was
gypped
ray fisher certainly was like
to command they act so much beautiful
work
that that man did i loved everything
they did with cyborg here and the zack
snyder's justice league
but this to me it's like you always hear
about whatever fandom is popular at the
time is
there's some article or something about
how they're the most toxic fan
too much if it's if it's freaking star
wars that's popular at the time it's
star wars is the most toxic fandom it
was bts k-pop group bts
toxic fan you know and then ralph boner
marvel
toxic fan and then uh snyder uh
cut is the same the same deal with uh
the snyder fans but
to me like when you go through like the
quote tweets here and all the love and
praise for such an emotionally powerful
scene
and a scene that is not like she's not a
superhero
she's not she's just an asian mom
you know yeah and it's still so powerful
my whole sequence i wanted to make sure
that even if you haven't heard the story
that
you know share share this story around
because this is this is one of the best
things to come out of this
whole movement in my opinion i hope zack
snyder becomes aware of this too
yeah absolutely all right guys well zack
snyder's justice league keep
check us out uh patreon for the full
length subscribe to youtube and
click that notification bell hit that
like button we'll do a spoiler review
this weekend too
see you guys